OUR CHENEY SORRY AUGUST TWELFTH
CLEARLY WELCOME BACK AUGUST
TWELFTH HEARING THIS IS NOT
JANUARY. AND WE DO HAVE ONE ACR
IN THEM. WE WILL BEGIN FIRST DO
WE HAVE YES WE DO WE HAVE CORMS
WE WILL BEGIN WITH. ROLL CALL
PLEASE. LIVE ON. CAN OKAY HAN.
BURKE CERVANTES CHOI. CHOI YEAH.
GABRIEL GRAYSON MELENDEZ. MARK
STONE. WEBER WICKS. MEDICAL
CREATE WE HAVE QUORUM THANK YOU
I'D LIKE TO INVITE US ON A
NUMBER OF KAMLAGER-DOVE WHO HAS
ACR ONE FIFTEEN AND THAT SHE
WILL BE PRESENTING TODAY. A
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I HOPE EVERYONE HAD A
RESTFUL. RECESS. I AM HERE
PRESENTING AC ARE ONE ONE FIVE
WHICH URGES BANKS THAT HAVE
OPENED DEMAND ACCOUNTS WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO STOP
LENDING TO GUN MANUFACTURERS. I
THINK AND HOPE THAT WE ARE ALL
COMMITTED TO ENDING GUN
VIOLENCE. THERE ARE WAY TOO
MANY GUN RELATED INCIDENTS THAT
ARE HAPPENING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SEE AND
READ ABOUT IN THE NEWS. AND
AFTER EACH SUCH INCIDENT WE
MOURN THE DEATHS AND SYMPATHIZE
WITH THE VICTIMS BUT DO LITTLE
TO REDUCE OUR OWN VULNERABILITY.
TO TRY AND PREVENT MASS
SHOOTINGS AND TO PREVENT OTHER
FIREARM RELATED PROBLEMS SUCH
AS HOMICIDES SUICIDES GUN
ROBBERY GUN INTIMIDATIONS AND
GUN ACCIDENTS. I BELIEVE WE
MUST ACT ON ALL FRONTS TO
ADDRESS GUN CONTROL. THIS
INCLUDES INVESTIGATING THE
FINANCIAL QUESTION OF GUN
MANUFACTURING. AS IT STANDS
CALIFORNIA HAS ESTABLISHED A
HUNDRED AND NINE GUN CONTROL
LAWS AND HAS BEEN A BREEDING
GROUND FOR ANTI GUN VIOLENCE
ACTIVISM. AND YET SIX OF THE
BANKS CALIFORNIA HAS ACCOUNTS
WITH HAVE PRIORITIZE PROFIT
OVER CALIFORNIAN VALUES. WHY DO
BANKS REMAIN RELATIVELY QUIET
WHILE CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN SO
VOCAL ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE AND
GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION. THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS SHOWN THAT SINCE
TWENTY FIFTEEN SIX IN TEN
CALIFORNIANS WANT STRICTER GUN
LAWS. BANK OF AMERICA CITY BANK
JPMORGAN CHASE BANK U. S. BANK
UNION BANK AND WELLS FARGO BANK
ARE PROVIDING LOANS OR LINE OF
CREDIT TO GUN MANUFACTURERS
WHICH A MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE DEEMED A
SOCIAL HAZARD. CITY BANK IS A
POSITIVE EXAMPLE OF A
CALIFORNIA BANKING INSTITUTION
THAT HAS TAKEN THE LEAD AND IS
SLOWLY DIVESTING FROM GUN
MANUFACTURERS. AND YET THERE
ARE OTHERS WHO SPEAK OF CODE OF
ETHICS. PROMISING TO SPEAK UP
WHEN THEY SEE SOMETHING. AND
TALKING ABOUT THE ABILITY TO DO
THE RIGHT THING IN MAKING SURE
THAT THEY ARE DOING THE RIGHT
THING AS FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
WHEN IT IS NOT THE EASY THING
TO DO AND YET THEY MAKE NO
PUBLIC STANCE ON DOING BUSINESS
WITH THE GUN INDUSTRY AND HAVE
CONTINUED TO FINANCE MILLIONS.
WITH THE GUN INDUSTRY. NOW
THESE BANKS ARE NOT BREAKING
ANY LAWS AND THIS IS A
RESOLUTION IT IS NOT A
RESOLUTION ABOUT BREAKING LAWS
IT IS A RESOLUTION TALKING
ABOUT. CHANGING BEHAVIOR. IT'S
A RESOLUTION ABOUT VALUES. WHY
IS IT OKAY THAT WE ASK OUR
PARENTS TO BUY BULLET PROOF
BACKPACKS. BUT WE'RE NOT
WILLING TO ASK BANKS TO
RECONSIDER LENDING TO
MANUFACTURERS RESPONSIBLE FOR
MAKING GUNS. I URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENCOURAGE
INVESTING WITH INSTITUTIONS
THAT PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
VALUES. WITH ME IN SUPPORT
TODAY IS AMANDA WILCOX FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE BRADY
UNITED AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN I'M AMANDA
WILCOX WITH BRADY CALIFORNIA
UNITED AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE WE
HAVE CHAPTERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE MANY OF OUR MEMBERS
INCLUDING MYSELF HAVE LOST A
LOVED ONE CAN TO GUNFIRE.
NORMAN BEFORE HE WON THE PUBLIC
MANY OF YOU IN THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE AND I'LL BE
FOURTH RIGHT FROM THE GET GO TO
MET THAT I DO NOT HAVE MUCH
BACKGROUND EXPERIENCE IN
FINANCIAL OR BANKING MATTERS
I'VE BEEN A LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE AS A VOLUNTEER FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS IN OUR STATE.
CALIFORNIA'S YOU PROBABLY KNOW
CALIFORNIA HAS A STRONG THIS
GUN LAWS IN THE NATION. AND
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY THREE WE
HAVE DROPPED HER GUN DEATH RATE
BY 55% ALMOST FOUR TIMES THE
DECREASE IN THE REST OF THE
NATION. OUR GUN LAWS ARE MAKING
A DIFFERENCE. BUT NONE THE LESS
WITH OVER THREE THOUSAND
FIREARM DEATHS IN CALIFORNIA IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT'S THE
LAST YEAR FOR WHICH WE HAVE
DATA. CLEARLY MORE MUST BE DONE.
NOT AND ONE OF THE PROTESTERS
TO ADDRESS THE PROLIFERATION OF
GUNS. THE RESEARCH IS VERY
CLEAR THAT WHERE THERE ARE MORE
GUNS THERE ARE MORE FIREARM
DEATH WE HAVE THE INDUSTRY AND
OUR NATION WHOSE PURPOSE IS TO
SELL MORE GUNS AND MAKE MONEY.
ARE THE NRA I THINK IT'S FAIR
TO SAY REPRESENTS THE GUN
INDUSTRY GUN MANUFACTURERS NOT
THE PUBLIC AS THE PUBLIC ARE.
THE LARGE MAJORITY OF THE
PUBLIC OVER 90% SUPPORT
BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR ALL GUN
SALES. 87% ARE SUPPORT RED FLAG
WORD COMBINES RESTRAINING ORDER
TYPE LAWS I THINK IT'S IN THE
LATE HI SIXTIES PERCENT SUPPORT
ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN. THE
MISMATCH BETWEEN WHAT
WASHINGTON. DOES NOT TO IN
TERMS OF GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION. AND WHERE THE
PUBLIC OPINION IS ON THIS ISSUE
IS BECAUSE OF THE POWER
INFLUENCE OF THE GUN INDUSTRY
WE NEED TO PUSH BACK AGAINST
GUN INDUSTRY AND ONE WAY TO DO
THAT. AS I SUGGESTED BY THIS
RESOLUTION IS TO STOP THE
LENDING TO GUN MANUFACTURERS
WORE OUT SO THAT THEY CAN'T BE
IN A BAY HAVE TO GO ELSEWHERE
AND MAY BE PAUSE IF THEY'RE
LOSING THAT KIND OF THING
FINANCING FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BANKS THAT WORK WITH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S BEEN OTHER EFFORTS
SUCCESSFUL EFFORTS TO GET THE
GUN INDUSTRY TO CHANGE BEHAVIOR
BOB FROM FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
PUTTING PRESSURE ON. FOR
EXAMPLE NOT SELLING GUNS TO
UNDER TWO PEOPLE AGE TWENTY ONE
OR NOT TELLING ASSAULT WEAPONS
THERE HAVE BEEN EFFORTS TO
CHANGE BEHAVIOR SO THAT FEWER
INAPPROPRIATE PEOPLE ARE
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS PEOPLE
HAVE ACCESS TO FIREARMS. AND I
THINK THIS EFFORT TO. A
RESOLUTION AND THE LANDING TO
GUN MANUFACTURERS AND THAT'S
THAT SOME REMEMBER SAID THIS IS
A NEW LAW IT'S A RESOLUTION.
BUT I THINK IT'S A STATEMENT OF
NOT ONLY WERE CALIFORNIA IS BUT
WORK WHERE OUR NATION IS. ON
THIS MATTER THAT WE ARE IN A
CRISIS IN OUR COUNTRY RIGHT NOW
WITH GUN VIOLENCE WE NEED ALL
APPROACHES. TO DEAL WITH THIS
CRISIS AND THIS IS ONE WAY IS
SIGNIFICANT WAY I THINK THAT WE
CAN PUSH BACK ON GUN
MANUFACTURERS IN THE GUN
INDUSTRY. TIRED YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. ANY ARE OF.
ANY THE SORRY WELCOME BACK TO
PER SE SO ANY OTHER AT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT PLEASE
COME TO THE MICROPHONE JUST
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION PLEASE. COMING
QUICK BAY AREA STUDENT
ACTIVISTS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SEEN NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT I'D LIKE TO INVITE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO COME
TO THE TABLE. SCENE. NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WILL
TAKE MEMBER COMMENTS WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS THANK YOU
ONE I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHORS
FOR BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION
FORWARD AND WE SAID ON PUBLIC
SAFETY TOGETHER WE SEE ALL THE
TIME A PUBLIC SAFETY AS WELL
YOU KNOW I THINK WITH THIS
RESOLUTION DOES THAT AIMS TO
GET REALLY IT TO THE SUPPLY
CHAIN QUESTION AND THE UPSTREAM
PART OF THE TRAGEDIES THAT WE
SEE AND FEEL AND EXPERIENCE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES WHICH WE'VE
OBVIOUSLY HAD MORE RECENT.
TRAGEDIES AS OF LATE WHICH IS
DEEPLY SADDENING UNFORTUNATE
AND I THINK WHAT THE BILL OR
WHAT SORRY WHAT THE RESOLUTION
IS TRYING TO DO IS TO SAY OKAY
THROUGH THE SUPPLY CHAIN AT
EVERY LEVEL HOW ARE WE ALL
TAKING A DEEP LOOK AT WHAT OUR
COLLECTIVE RESPONSIBILITY AS
INCLUDING OUR BANKS SO I THINK
IT'S A CRITICAL RESOLUTION AND
I THINK WE ALL HAVE TO LOOK AT
WHEN WE HAVE THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND DEATHS A YEAR WHO'S
CONTRIBUTING TO THAT RIGHT AND
HOW WE'RE ALL TAKING PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR SOLVING THIS
PROBLEM SO I JUST WANTED TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. WOULD LOVE TO BE
A CO AUTHOR AND DO ANYTHING I
CAN TO SUPPORT IT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MELINDA'S THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR ASSEMBLY WOMAN
I JUST I NEED TO KNOW WHAT IS
THE GOAL. BEHIND THIS
RESOLUTION YOU WANT. GUN
MANUFACTURERS AND RETAILERS TO
NOT HAVE A FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION WITH WHICH TO BANK
IS THAT THE GOAL THE GOAL IS TO
EXPAND THE CONVERSATION THAT
WE'VE BEEN HAVING AROUND GUN
VIOLENCE AND GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION OKAY BUT YOUR
ISOLATION DOESN'T ASK FOR
CONVERSATION IT ENCOURAGES
BANKS TO NOT DO BUSINESS WITH
GUN MANUFACTURERS AND GUN
RETAILERS SO THAT'S WHY I'M
SAYING IT'S LEADING ME TO
BELIEVE THAT YOUR GOAL IS TO BE
IS TO PUT GUN MANUFACTURERS AND
RETAILERS IN A POSITION WHERE
THEY DON'T HAVE A FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION. WITH WHICH TO DO
BUSINESS IS THAT YOUR GOAL THAT
IS ONE OF THE GOALS BUT THIS
RIGHT HERE IS THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE'RE HAVING JUST BECAUSE
WE BROUGHT THE RESOLUTION
FORWARD WE TEND TO HAVE A
NUMBER OF CONVERSATIONS AS IT
RELATES TO GUN VIOLENCE
SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY ON THE
DEMAND SIDE THE FOLKS WHO WANT
TO PURCHASE A GUN THE FOLKS WHO
HAVE A GUN IF THEY HAVE A GUN
THAT'S- BEEN LEGALLY PURCHASED
OR NOT. WHERE THEY'RE BUYING
THE GUN FROM WHO THE DEALER IS
HOW MUCH AMMUNITION THEY'RE
ALLOWED TO PER WHAT'S BILLION A
DAY IS THAT OF ANY FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS SO THAT HAS BEEN
THE KINDS OF CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE'VE BEEN HAVING THIS IS
SAYING LET'S HAVE A DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION ALSO AS IT RELATES
TO GUN VIOLENCE AND GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION AND TALK
ABOUT THE SUPPLY SIDE YOU
CANNOT HAVE A GUN IF THE GUN IS
NOT BEEN MADE. YOU CANNOT SELL
A GUN THAT HAS NOT BEEN MADE
THE REALITY IS THERE FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION GUNS IN THIS
COUNTRY SO EVERYONE STILL HAS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO AT LEAST HAVE
ONE. BUT I AM CERTAINLY NOT
INTERESTED IN JUST TALKING
ABOUT THE DEMAND SIDE THE OTHER
REALITY IS WE LIVE. IN A FREE
MARKET SOCIETY SO I THINK IT'S
PRESUMPTUOUS TO SAY IF YOU
CANNOT GO TO ONE LENDING
INSTITUTION THEN YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO MANUFACTURE A
GUN IS SHOT. THAT'S KIND OF THE
INCENTIVE TO LIVING IN A FREE
MARKET CAPITALISTIC SOCIETY
IT'S ALSO I THINK UNFAIR TO
SUGGEST. THAT THIS IS THE YOU
KNOW THE ONLY PRODUCT THAT'S
AVAILABLE FOR LENDING
INSTITUTIONS TO INVESTING IN
ORDER TO MAKE MONEY WE HAVE
SEEN THAT PROVE ITSELF NOT TO
BE TRUE IN HISTORY AS IT
RELATES TO YOU KNOW. INSTANCES
LIKE DIVESTING IN SOUTH AFRICA.
COMPANIES STILL FOUND WAYS TO
EARN MONEY AND TO BE SOCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE. OKAY I AM EVEN
MORE CONFUSING I'M YOU. YOU
STATED THAT YOUR GOAL IS TO GET
TO THE POINT WHERE THESE
MANUFACTURERS AND RETAILERS
HAVE NO FINANCIAL INSTITUTION
TO DO BUSINESS WITH YOU ALSO
MADE A COMMENT ABOUT. IF THE
GUN DOESN'T EXIST THING YOU
CAN'T BUY IT SO I GUESS THE
OTHER PART OF THE GOAL IS TO.
JUST GET TO A POINT WHERE.
THESE WEAPONS AREN'T BEING
MANUFACTURED IS THAT PART OF
THE GOAL THAT LESS GUNS OUR
MAIN GOAL IS TO ENCOURAGE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS TO
RECONSIDER. THOSE WITH HOME
THEY LAND DEBT TO SPECIFICALLY
TARGETING GUN MANUFACTURERS
OKAY SO THEN. MEAN
IDEOLOGICALLY WE'RE COMPLETE
OPPOSITES ON THIS ISSUE WHICH
IS WHICH IS FINE I'M JUST. I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IF. THERE
HAS BEEN FOLLOW THROUGH IN
THINKING ABOUT THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF SOMETHING LIKE
THIS FOR INSTANCE EVERY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. NEEDS FIREARMS.
SO IF YOU ENCOURAGE. LENDING
INSTITUTIONS TO NOT. DO
BUSINESS WITH THE GUN
MANUFACTURERS AND RETAILERS
WHERE THEN WELL OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES JUST AS
ONE EXAMPLE GET THEIR FULL GET
THEIR FIREARMS FOR THEIR
OFFICERS TO DO THEIR JOB WELL
THIS IS SPECIFICALLY TARGETING
THOSE BANKS THAT HAVE OPEN
ACCOUNTS WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIANS CHIANG MAI
QUESTIONS SO THE OTHER THING IS
BANK OF AMERICA. AND CITI GROUP.
HAVE TAKEN MEASURES. IN THIS
ARENA AT BANK OF AMERICA FOR
EXAMPLE HAS STOP LENDING TO
COMPANIES THAT MAKE MILITARY
INSPIRED FIREARMS FOR CIVILIAN
USE AND CITY GROUP ONLY WORKS
WITH CLIENTS THAT HAVE AGREED
TO CERTAIN RESTRICTIONS ON
FIREARMS SALES. SO THAT AND ONE
OF THOSE BANKS REFINANCED
REMINGTON OUTDOOR WHICH
MANUFACTURES ASSAULT WEAPONS.
YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
WELL UNFORTUNATELY I THINK WE
CAN HAVE IT BOTH WAYS ALL THE
TIME. SO OKAY. I JUST I JUST
WANT TO HEAR THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION OR TO MY QUESTION
WHICH IS. IF ALL OF OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES MUST
PURCHASE THEIR FIREARMS FROM
SOMEONE. WHERE WILL THEY- SO
I'M WHERE WILL THEY GO THERE
ARE WITH A PAYING CASH. THERE
ARE OVER A DOZEN. FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS. THAT LAND DEBT TO
GUN MANUFACTURERS. I DON'T HAVE
INFORMATION WITH ME CURRENTLY
THAT WILL TELL ME. WHERE ALL OF
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT ENTITIES
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ARE PURCHASING THEIR GUNS. IN
ORDER FOR ME TO SPECIFICALLY
ANSWER THE QUESTION THAT YOU'RE
ASKING I DON'T BELIEVE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS PAYING CASH
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS RESOLUTION
IS SAYING THIS RESOLUTION IS
ENCOURAGING FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS THAT LAND THAT
HAVE OPEN ACCOUNTS WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
REEVALUATE. THEIR LENDING
PRACTICES TO THOSE THAT
MANUFACTURE GUNS. OKAY WELL
THANK YOU AND I DON'T HAVE ANY
MORE QUESTIONS AND I KNOW IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE A SHORT HEARING
I WILL JUST SAY THAT I THINK
THE THIRD OFF A LOT OF THINGS
WRONG WITH THIS RESOLUTION EVEN
THIS IS THIS ISN'T LEGALLY
BINDING IT DOESN'T CHANGE THE
LAW. BUT IT CERTAINLY IF I WERE
A FINANCIAL INSTITUTION I WOULD
TAKE IT AS A THREAT. I WOULD
TAKE IT AS A THREAT COMING
FROM. THE LEGISLATURE SAYING IF
YOU DON'T IMPOSE OUR WILL ON
YOUR CLIENTS. THERE WILL BE
CONSEQUENCES AND I DON'T THINK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE.
PART PARTICIPATING IN THAT SORT
OF BEHAVIOR BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
PARTICULAR VALUE OR IDEOLOGICAL
VIEW POINT THAT YOU WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE ELSE IN
THE STATE MUST SHARE. STARTING
WITH FINANCIAL INSTITUTION I
THINK THAT'S A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT TO SET. AND I THINK
LOOK TO THE FUTURE. WHERE THE
TABLES MIGHT BE TURNED IN YOU
MIGHT NOT LIKE THE WAY SOMEONE
ELSE IMPOSES THIS THIS TYPE OF
LEGISLATION ON OTHER INDUSTRY
SO THAT'S ALL I HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI. THANK YOU
CHAIR. ASSEMBLYMAN KNOCKED ON
LIKE A DAHLE VIA I OR SO WOULD
LIKE TO ADD US SOME OF MY
FEELINGS AND THE QUESTIONS SO I
THINK I UNDERSTAND YOUR. INTENT
THAT IS ONE WAY THE OF HELPING.
REDUCING GUN VIOLENCE. IN THE
WAKE OF US SO MANY. MASS
SHOOTING SAID THAT THAT HAVE
TAKEN PLACE AND THAT GOING ON
IN THE WILL CALL ON IN
OBVIOUSLY. I COME FROM. A
COUNTRY. WHERE PROFIT THE
OWNERSHIP IS A TOTALLY BANNED
FROM SOUTH KOREA AND OTHER THAN
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
MILITARY. AND BUT THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT THAT THERE MAY BE
SOME ILLEGAL PRIVATE DONORS IT
MAY BE BUT IT IS TOTALLY BAD
SO. I UNDERSTOOD THAT CONCEPT
THE BUT THE WHEN I ARRIVED HERE.
OUR I MEAN THIS IS SO OUT IN
THE CONSTITUTION. YEAH IS THAT
THE PROHIBITING GUN OWNERSHIP
QUARTERLY I MEAN NOTE THAT NOT
ALL OF. PROHIBITING. IN THE
WEST A PROTECTING GUARD
OWNERSHIP BY INDIVIDUAL. AND A
NOW I UNDERSTOOD THAT THE WHY
THAT WAS SO IMPORTANT TO IN
THIS COUNTRY THAT THAT HAS TO
BE. INSCRIBED IN THE EVEN IN
OUR CONSTITUTION. IN THIS
COUNTRY OF A VAST LAND AND A
PIONEER. A FROM THE EAST TO THE
WEST. NO LAW. YEAH FIGHTING
AGAINST ALL KINDS OF ELEMENTS.
EXPORTS TO SOAR YOU ARE THE ALL
IN ALL A SO I MEAN GUN
OWNERSHIP I THINK THAT THAT IS
A DEEPLY ROOTED HOW IMPORTANT
THE PROTECTING INDIVIDUAL AW
YEAH LIFE AND PROPERTY AND ALSO
IN THIS COUNTRY WE- ARE THE
COUNTRY OP ARE MADE UP OF A
IMMIGRANTS. AND IT IS SON NOT
JUST A HOME WITH GENIUS SO WE
VERY MULTI. RACIAL OR ETHNIC
THE. ULTRA OUR DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS THAT DOES NOT HELP
TO UNDERSTAND. NOT TOTALLY
HOMOGENEOUS A CULTURAL
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THINKING IS
TOTALLY DIFFERENT IN ALSO. AT
THAT THE ONLY THE AYE AYE.
STUDY AND THE THOUGHT ABOUT WHY
CAN OWNERSHIP BUT IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE BUT NOW WE ARE
FACING A LOT OF A DEBATE
BECAUSE OF A GUN RELATED
VIOLENCE IS. I MEAN NOT THAT
WOULD BE NO ONE. ARE ANYWHERE.
COOL ORDER CONDONE AND
ENCOURAGE OR LACK THAT THAT
KIND OF A YOU CAN RELATE TO.
VIOLENCE AND THE MASS KILLING
WITH THE WEAPONS. A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS THAT WE CAN RAISE. AT
THAT BUT THE WHEN WE PROHIBITS
POORLY CAN OWNERSHIP IN THIS
COUNTRY. I DON'T KNOW WHERE
THIS COUNTRY WOULD GO IN THAT
THE ORIGIN ARE BASIC BUT
INDIVIDUAL LIBERTY AND FREEDOM
TO PROTECT MY LIFE IN THE MY
PROPERTY GET IN WITH THE
DISCOUNT ABOUT CULTURE AND THE
BACKGROUND ON. WHY THE GUN
OWNERSHIP BUT BECAME SO
IMPORTANT. SO IT WILL BE AT A
TO ME ON CONCEIVABLE. THE
UNITED STATES SO. OF AMERICA
ONE DAY. OUT WILL BE BEN
INDIVIDUAL A GUN OWNERSHIP. WE
HAVE INSTITUTED A DID YOU SAY
ONE OH NINE DIFFERENT KINDS OF
APPEARANCE THAT THE TRYING TO
SCREEN AND INVESTIGATE THE
BACKGROUND OF UP ARE INTENDED
GUN NOT PURCHASES SO AS TO
STUDY WHAT KIND OF CRAZY GUYS
ARE TRYING TO BUY A GUN Là
MENTALLY UNSTABLE GUY SICK GUY
IS. DRUNK BY SO WE'RE TRYING TO
PULL OFF. THE PERIOD THE ANGRY
PEORIA AT THE BY CERTAIN THEN I
ALL UNDERSTAND THAT THE- BUT
THE WHEN YOU TRY TO. INTRODUCED
AS SUCH RESOLUTION EVEN THOUGHT
THAT IS ON NOT ENFORCEABLE IT'S
A SORT ABA ENCOURAGEMENT. BUT
THE NOW YOU MENTIONED ON
SEVERAL TIME COUPLE TIMES THAT
THAT THE FREE MARKET THE
CONCEPT. WHEN IF YOU TO
INTRODUCE AT THIS KIND OF A-
RESOLUTION. AND THEN A HOLLOW
WITH THIS WOULD BE PERCEIVED.
BY THOSE INDUSTRY AND THE BANKS.
WHAT YOU ARE TRYING TO DO WHAT
WOULD BE I MEAN TO ME IT'S
ALMOST A LACK OF WRITING ON THE
WALL WHAT IS COMING. THAT THE
ORDER VIA TOTALLY IF STEP AND
COREY RESOLUTION DOESN'T WORK.
IT CAN BE SOON INTRODUCED A HEY
YOU DIDN'T LISTEN. IN A WITH
YET GENTLE ENCOURAGEMENT. BY A
AT THIS RESOLUTION THEN WE CAN
I INTRODUCED A BILL. NOW THAT
THAT THAT IS ALL OR MOST ALL IN
ALL. T. MOBILE NEXT STEP. AND A
WHAT WOULD BE THE NEXT TO KIND
OF INDUSTRY THAT WE LEGISLATORS
SO WE TRY TO A BAND BANGSA NOT
TO DO ANY BUSINESS ANY ANY
INDUSTRY ABOUT BUSINESS SO ODD
THAT THAT WE DON'T NOT LACK
HILL SO THIS IS OUR QUARTERLY.
THE ARE INCOMPATIBLE WERE
CONCEPT OF AMERICAN CAPITALISM
AND FREE MARKET GAME AND THAT'S
A SHOULD BE A NOT BANKS WON'T
PRINCIPLE. WHOM YOU WILL NOT DO
BUSINESS WITH. OKAY THE OTHER
QUESTION IS THAT IF YOU DO BàN
OR PROHIBIT TO ENCOURAGE THE
RULE OF OUR SOLUTION ON ALL OF.
AS A ASSEMBLY MEMBER LISA
MELENDEZ INDICATED THAT THERE
ARE TWO SIDES OF MONEY IS A
CONSUMER USE AT THE OTHER ONE
IS OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT MILITARY
AWHILE PLEASE AWARE NEVER. SO
WHAT WOULD BE THE CONSEQUENCES
OF THE WARSAW SO I YOU WANNA.
AMERICAN EXCEPTION IF YOU NEED
THE MILLION DOLLAR LOAN TO A
MANUFACTURER ARE ASSAULT
WEAPONS SO THAT WILL BE SOLD
THE TO MILITARY ALONE THEN. YOU
CAN DO LOAN BANKING. AND THEY
GIVE THE LOW. IT SOUNDS LIKE
THEY'RE SUCH YOU QUESTIONS NESN
DOT I MEAN RAISING NUMBER OF
WITH THINGS SUCH AS I SPEAK SO
I AM BASICALLY SAYING THAT THAT
THIS APPROACH EVEN THOUGHT I
UNDERSTAND YOU OR WRITTEN
INTENT. BUT THE WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THIS KIND OF PRINCE
SPORTS SO AND THEN ALSO NEXT
THAT IMPLEMENTATION IN ALL OF
THIS IS SAID TO ME A VIOLATION
OF A FREE KIND OF PRETTY MARKET
CONCEPT THE AND INDIVIDUAL
RIGHTS. AND THE FREEDOM ARE
FULL. IF THE INDUSTRIAL
INDIVIDUALS OF DOING BUSINESS.
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION STAGE IS
GOING TO BE VERY VERY DIFFICULT
HOW WE CANNOT DISTINGUISH A WE
WILL NEED THE PRODUCTION OF
WEAPONS SELF FOR NATIONAL
DEFENSE SO OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHATEVER. MIGHT SOLA CERTAIN
COMPANIES WILL BE DEDICATED TO
ON THE MANUFACTURING THOSE KIND
OF WEAPONS BUT THE OTHER
COMPANY WILL BE ONLY SELLING TO
INDIVIDUALS. SO IT IN THAT
CORDOBA. LEVEL IT WILL BE.
CONFUSING ALL CONCEPT AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PARTY
HASTA SO IF YOU HAVE A THOUGHT
ABOUT THE OR THIS ASPECTS OF
MAYBE YOU CAN. IN A COMMENT
THAT FEW OF MY THOUGHTS AND
PRIOR TO THE MEMBER. COMMENTING
I DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. WE
ARE ALL TALKING ABOUT THE SAME
RESOLUTION AS YOU WILL NOTE
THIS ONLY APPLIES TO SIX OPEN
DEMAND ACCOUNTS I AND PAGE TWO
OF THE RESOLUTION IF YOU LOOK
UNDER SECTION TWO DISCUSSION
ALSO CLARIFIES THAT OTHER BANKS
NONBANK LENDERS PRIVATE EQUITY
AND BOND MARKETS WOULD. LIKELY
EQUALLY SUPPLY CREDIT TO GUN
MANUFACTURERS TO FILL THE GAPS
THAT WOULD BE IMPACTED THAT
COULD. BE IMPACTED THIS IS NOT
A BILL THIS IS A RESOLUTION SO
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WERE ALL. THAT WILL HAVE THE
ANALYSIS IN FRONT OF US AND CAN
LEAD TO THAT SO WITH THAT IF
YOU'D LIKE TO. COMMENT YOU'RE
WELCOME TO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FOR THAT CLARIFICATION
AND THANK YOU MISTER CHOI FOR
ALL OF YOUR THOUGHTS AND YOUR
COMMENTS. I DO WANNA JUST SORT
OF RESPOND TO A FEW THINGS THIS
IS NOT A SECOND AMENDMENT BAIL
AS THE MADAM CHAIR MENTIONED IT
IS THE RESOLUTION AND SO I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOUR FOR
SITE ABOUT WHAT CAN HAPPEN DOWN
THE LINE. BUT ANY OF THOSE
THINGS THAT WOULD HAPPEN DOWN
THE LINE WOULD SEE THEMSELVES
IN A BILL AND A DIFFERENT KIND
OF BILL PROBABLY GOING TO
MULTIPLE COMMITTEES. YOU TALK A
LOT ABOUT SORT OF
IMPLEMENTATION WHAT WOULD THIS
MEAN. YOU KNOW ULTIMATELY TO
THE POINT OF MISS MELENDEZ THIS
IS ABOUT YOU KNOW HAVING A
CONVERSATION A LARGER
CONVERSATION IN WHICH WE ALL
HAVE A COLLECTIVE
RESPONSIBILITY. WE HAVE SEEN IN
MANY OF OUR COMMITTEES THAT
WHEN WE ARE LOOKING AT SPECIFIC
OR CERTAIN KINDS OF BILLS THAT
DEAL WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFTENTIMES THERE ARE CERTAIN
EXEMPTIONS THAT ARE PLACED. BUT
ONCE AGAIN THAT'S WITH
FORESIGHT OF A DIFFERENT KIND
OF BILL COMING BEFORE. WHO
KNOWS WHO'S COMMITTEES YOU KNOW
ON THOSE PARTICULAR ISSUES I'M
THIS IS NOT SAYING THAT GUN
MANUFACTURERS HAVE TO STOP
MAKING GUNS THIS BILL DOES THIS
RESOLUTION IS INSANE PEOPLE
HAVE TO STOP BUYING. THIS BILL
IS SPECIFIC AND FOCUSED ON
THOSE BANKS THAT HAVE OPEN
ACCOUNTS WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW AS I
MENTIONED. YOU KNOW BANK OF
AMERICA AND CITIGROUP HAVE
TAKEN IT UPON THEMSELVES TO
CURTAIL CERTAIN WAYS OF
PRACTICES AND POLICIES AS IT
RELATES TO DEALING WITH GUN
MANUFACTURERS YOU KNOW DELTA
HURTS AND DICK'S SPORTING GOODS
HAVE ALSO TAKEN MEASURES TO
KIND OF STOP OPERATING.
BUSINESS AS USUAL IN RESPONSE
TO A NUMBER OF THE MASS
SHOOTINGS THAT HAVE HAPPENED IN
THE EIGHTIES AND THE NINETIES
OVER TWO HUNDRED CORPORATIONS
YOU KNOW HE DID THE CALL FOR
DIVESTMENT IN SOUTH AFRICA AND
SAID WHAT KIND OF POLICIES AND
PRACTICES. CAN WE PUT IN PLACE
TO STOP THIS BECAUSE WE'RE
HAVING A LARGER CULTURAL
CONVERSATION. ABOUT SOUTH
AFRICA AND APARTHEID I THINK. I
MEAN IF GILROY IF DAYTON OHIO
AND CHICAGO ILLINOIS YOU KNOW
IF EL PASO TEXAS OF SANDY HOOK
I MEAN NAME IS CITY PICK A
CITY. IF THOSE SHOOTINGS DON'T
SUGGEST THAT WE SHOULD HAVE A
COLLECTIVE CONVERSATION. AND
ASK FOR A CULTURAL CHANGE AND
HOW WE VIEW. THE SECOND
AMENDMENT AND HOW WE VIEW THE
RIGHT TO PROTECT OUR BUSINESS
OUR FAMILY AND HOW WE VIEW THE
SAFETY AND SECURITY. OF THE
FOLKS THAT WERE WALKING NEXT TO
WHEN WE GO TO THE FARMER'S
MARKET OR WHEN WE GO TO A
BARBECUE AS IT RELATES TO HOW
OTHER FOLKS HANDLE GUNS. IF
THIS ISN'T THE TIME I DON'T
KNOW WHEN IT WILL BE. SOME
PEOPLE MAY VIEW THIS AS A
THREAT AND HOPEFULLY IT'S AN
ENCOURAGEMENT THOUGH. TO SAY
HOW CAN WE PLAY A ROLE IN
SOLVING THIS LARGER ISSUE
BECAUSE NO BILL THAT WE
INTRODUCE NOT EVEN THIS
RESOLUTION AS THE SILVER BULLET
RESPONSE. BUT I BELIEVE THAT WE
ALL CAN PLAY A ROLE IN THE
LARGER CONVERSATION. AND COME
TO SOME PATH FORWARD WHERE
YOUNG PEOPLE AREN'T. DUCKING
BEHIND DOORS AND UNDER CHAIRS
BECAUSE A CAR GOES OFF AND THEY
THINK IT'S A GUN. OR BECAUSE
PARENTS DON'T HAVE PTSD ABOUT
GOING SHOPPING. BECAUSE THEY'RE
AFRAID THAT THE RECEIPT CHECKER.
IT'S GOING TO GET SHOT IN THEIR
CHILD IS STANDING NEXT TO THAT
PERSON. THIS IS ASKING
INSTITUTIONS THAT NORMALLY HAVE
NOT BEEN ASKED TO THINK ABOUT
THEIR POWER POP POLICIES AND
PRACTICES TO DO SO. THANK YOU
AT MEMBERS ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND SIGN OUR BARRICADE HAND.
I JUST WANNA AND ECHO MISS
WORKS COMMENTS REAL BRIEFLY AND
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THE RESOLUTION I THINK
IT'S CRAFTED IN A REALLY
THOUGHTFUL WAY IT MERELY ASKS
THE BANKS THAT WE AS A STATE DO
BUSINESS WITH. DOT PRACTICES
THAT REFLECT THIS IS THE
WORDING OF THE RESOLUTION FACT
VALUES OF CALIFORNIA PROTECTING
CITIZENS BEFORE PROFIT.
ANYTHING TO ASK THE
INSTITUTIONS WE DO BUSINESS
WITH TO DO WHAT WE DO EVERY
DAY. AND WORK FOR THE VALUES OF
CALIFORNIA IS NOT TOO MUCH TO
ASK. AND I THINK YOU FOR ASKING
THEM TO DO SO AND I'M EXCITED
TO SUPPORTERS SAY SOMETHING.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
THOUGHTS. ALL RIGHT SEEN NONE I
THINK U. S. A SUMMER AT A THINK
THAT TO YOUR OBJECTIVE TO RAISE
A DISCUSSION IS EVIDENCED IN
TODAY'S HEARING ON THIS
RESOLUTION I THINK IT'S ALSO AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TO HAVE
AND NOT CLEAR WHERE THE
DIRECTION WOULD HAVE GONE HAD
THIS BEEN A POLICY PER SE.
GIVEN THE DYNAMICS BETWEEN THE
FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS BUT I DO
THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION TO HAVE ANYTHING
TODAY'S HEARING IS A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF WHY IT'S AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TO HAVE.
THIS I I'M GONNA ALLOW YOU AT
TO CLOSE AND THEN WE WILL CALL
THE ROLL BUT I DO WANT TO
MENTION THAT THIS RESOLUTION
HAS A DO PASSED TO BE ADOPTED
TO THIRD READING. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR TIME AND ALSO FOR YOUR
COMMENTS I JUST WANT TO CLOSE
BY SAYING THAT WE AS THE STATE.
OF INSERT OUR VALUES AND POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS IN MANY WAYS
WE'VE DONE THAT WITH THE TRAVEL
BAN WHEN WE FELT THAT YOU KNOW
FOLKS FROM OUR STATE WERE BEING
PERSECUTED OR FOLKS ON THE LGBT
COMMUNITY WERE BEING PERSECUTED
IN OTHER STATES. YOU KNOW WE
USED OUR POLICY BULLY PULPIT TO
SAY SOMETHING AND WE DID THAT
WHEN WELLS FARGO WAS CAUGHT
WITH FRAUDULENT ACCOUNTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA MADE A
DECISION A VALUE BASED DECISION
TO SAY THIS IS HOW WE'RE GOING
TO PROTECT. YOU KNOW THE
CITIZENS OF THE STATE AS IT
RELATES TO THIS FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION UNTIL IT GETS ITS
ACT TOGETHER SO WE DO THAT IN
SMALL AND LARGE WAYS. AND THIS
RESOLUTION IS JUST ADDING TO
THAT MENU OF CONVERSATIONS AND
ENCOURAGEMENT THAT WE'RE ASKING
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS TO STEP
UP AND STEP INTO AS IT RELATES
TO GUN VIOLENCE SO I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR
CONCERNS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE THAT. WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND CALL THE ROLL. BUSH'S BE
ADOPTED TO THIRD READING LEMOND
HI THE MORNING I CAN. OKAY ON
MY HEAD BALLOT QUE ONLINE BOOK
BOOK I CERVANTES SEVEN TO SITE
CHOI. TROY NO GABRIEL GABRIEL I
GRAYSON GRAYSON I MELENDEZ
LANDIS NO MARK STONE MARK STONE
AYE AND WEBER WHETHER I WICKS
WICKS I. THANK YOU AT THE VOTE
IS AT NINE TWO TWO AND WE WILL
WAIT FOR ANY ABSENCE MEMBERS
BUT THE MEASURE IS OUT. THANK
YOU
. ALL RIGHT SO WITH THAT WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND DURING THE
MEETING